en Perú los manifestantes siguen
exigiendo la dimisión de la presidenta
interina Dina boluarte y la celebración
inmediata de elecciones ante esa
movilización el gobierno ha decidido
extender el estado de emergencia la
presidenta de la República decreta a
partir del 15 de enero de 2023 por el
término de 30 días calendario el estado
de emergencia en los departamentos de
puno cusco Lima y en la provincia
constitucional del callao la medida
también aplica para otras cuatro
provincias y un Distrito está autorizada
ejército a intervenir para mantener el
orden y conlleva la suspensión de varios
derechos constitucionales como la
libertad de circulación y reunión y la
inviolabilidad del domicilio las
protestas estallaron a principios de
diciembre tras la destitución del
presidente Pedro Castillo acusado de
haber intentado perpetrar un golpe de
estado al querer disolver el parlamento
que se disponía a destituirlo desde
entonces los enfrentamientos entre
manifestantes y fuerzas de seguridad son
si el país está de luto 48 manifestantes
y un policía murieron la Comisión
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos que
visitó el país ha pedido la
investigación la comisión recibió
denuncias de disparos indiscriminados en
contra de personas manifestantes en
ciertas regiones frente a estos hechos
la comisión Recuerda que el estado tiene
el deber de realizar investigaciones
serias imparciales y efectivas por su
parte la presidenta se niega a renunciar
en un breve mensaje a la nación no
asumió ninguna responsabilidad en la
violencia de la represión contra los
manifestantes